hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to there's
nothing like an environmental film is
there that is to say there's nothing
more preachy annoying or obnoxiously
pretentious as an environmental film is
there of course there isn't and that's
why I'm taking a look at 20th Century
Fox's latest animation fuckup sense well
anything they're ambitious to do is
produced Ridley ferngully the last
rainforest Hellboy and I got some words
to say about hey what was it that was me
you plagiarist nostalgic what the hell
do you want you can't make fun of Furcal
I was gonna make fun of that hey two
minutes check I got dibs you don't have
the brainpower to understand the level
of bullshit this movie amounts to why I
put up with it from your end every
couple of weeks say that it oh you mean
what I just said about you constantly
spewing bullshit every time you speak
certainly I that's me the person right
in front of you put up that's a
direction with it being your bullshit
from your end I even go there every
couple of weeks that is a period of time
it's not slow enough for you well why
don't you come over here and say that
face-to-face to me big shot I got a
better idea
why don't you come up here and make me
say it to your face go ahead try it
I'll get something real evil here oh
you're right
this isn't about us this is about moving
a god-awful movie that deserves to be
ripped a new one what do you say truce
truce so the film begins as most epics
do with a flashback bastard bitch they
tell us that Fern Gully used to be a
peaceful forest of waving hands where
everybody was happy and peaceful all the
time yeah you don't there yes good but
then the plot device known as hexes
arrived an evil spirit who wanted to
spread chaos all over the way but then
an alliance of men and elves marched
against the armies of Texas putting that
bum hole in his place instead they used
some sort of wing magic bullshit that
helped defeat the evil exes and bring
life back to Fern Gully and one of those
examples of life is Tinker Bell's slutty
sister here Christa Christa when a
charming name it's like the name a wasp
family would give their child to make
them son unique give me a like Fern
Gully
yeah so she spends most of her time
flying around with other fairies while
listening to bad late eighties early
nineties music we do dendron eclis here
in the rainforest cafe our only forest
filled with Phil Collins one of these oh
except Tarzan they were unfortunate
enough to get the real Phil Collins okay
what's the password
welcome to help don't eat runs oh come
on you guys is that the password sounds
good bye good so she visits a mystical
something-or-other named Maggie who kind
of looks like Yoda senile German
grandmother I don't know it looked like
a strange black cloud rising out of the
earth smoke why should things what smoke
gee is this that naive and dangerous of
all animals known as
she shows Krista that if trouble does
come and ruin that the secret to all
growth isn't water light or the ability
to create your own food it's magic what
about the science that going on what
about the years of research magic damn
you ever tried to bring logic into this
movie again this is Fern Gully bitch and
speaking of impending danger Robin
Williams is in this movie too playing a
fruit bat named fatty which is another
weird name isn't that kind of like
calling a human inhuman he's a little
out of it because his mind was altered
by evil scientific experiments that
makes comic relief much more annoying
than they need to be pass the probe
graduate students all gather for imma
know it again I just blew in from a
biology lab I'm back and I'm flipping
free I'm a nocturnal placental flying
mammal a member of the family of Tara
did I or didn't I used to call me batty
batty koda nice to meet you Bonjour you
know how Robin Williams is both funny
and annoying it's like they took away
the funny just replace it with more
annoying well it's not like he could get
any more annoying
so yeah listening to Robin Williams rap
is kind of like listening to Eminem song
by M&Ms while taking part in S&M
annoying bad for you and incredibly
painful so Betty says he spotted humans
at melt warning which is wait a minute
melt warning isn't that in Australia
yeah is there rain for its in any kind
of danger forest
well mr. critic one must ask oneself
is a viable rainforest environment that
happens to have a ready supply of white
people Central America no beginning
getting warmer
oh yeah now you got it technically they
could have just made up a location but I
guess the movie wanted some credibility
now you could say that's not a great
idea to try to the close logical and
environmentalist film about fairies but
hey it's for kids and kids are stupid
enough to buy anything now I know and
knowing is half the battle so Krista
follows Benny to where he spotted the
humans and that's not the only thing
together great set up boom oh come on
why do you think he's flying behind her
so we come across that blond mullet
youth named Zack who's helping other
Australians with no accents chop down
the trees of their beloved rainforest
faster than you can say it's not the
size that counts
Zack has shrunken down to the size of a
fairy what is with this running blind in
this gag he's a fruit bat fruit bats
aren't blind while he's passed out
unconscious the little mugger and Krista
rummages through his pockets to see what
she can find maybe I can cut off this
root in his crotch area take anything
you want I won't tell the cops trust me
I'm not gonna tell me when I was mugged
by a fairy check this down fake sick
thing cousin ain't it oh I'm sorry we
seem to have entered into a completely
different movie
I just can't fish from within
one love ravenous consumption you're
welcome little snack if my dog ate
somebody it might as well be greatest
baking whether that which bomber strikes
exotic this what this character he just
comes out of nowhere singing this kind
of sexual song about how he's gonna eat
Zack I mean what's the point
oh it's a big lip delegator what's a big
alligator well that's not an alligator
itself that's not an alligator
you stupid second shit perhaps you don't
remember the big lift alligator seen
from all dogs go to women this is named
after the random musical number sunglass
big lift alligator towards the end of
the film a scene that comes right the
fuck out of nowhere has little to no
bearing whatsoever on the plot is way
over the top in terms of ridiculousness
even in the context of the movie and
after it happens
no one ever speaks at it again oh like
the dancing fire gang from Liberia the
pink elephants from Dumbo the creepy ass
tunnel scene from Willy Wonka that's
right
and all this festering pile of
pointlessness oh yeah I really am
well after that bit of nothing our two
main characters finally introduced
themselves to one another I'm Zach I'm
Kristin please the fucking I mean meet
you
Krista shows Zach around the forest
while those pesky stupid humans
foolishly unleash the monster hexxus
played by Tim Curry from his wooden
prison he then works his way into their
radio where he tells the workers to head
out and destroy Fern Gully dinner boss
used to be a woman when you turn into a
British guy we then hear hexxus
mmm singing about how he loves pollution
and how he considers their relationship
toxic love
[Music]
I'm just a cheap
sexually toxic me
[Music]
did that make any sense no are you ever
going to mention it again probably bad
delegator moment so Krista and Zack sit
and talk more about how the rain forest
is good and humans are the devil Patrese
gives life they make the clouds rain in
the air we've got air yeah you don't
mind getting all your minerals in one
breath don't you miss talking to the
forest what does it say yeah that sounds
cool nope usually it's warm no no cool
means hot you know bodacious bad tubular
as in you are one bodacious babe another
1992 cash phrases to show his sudden
romantic interest in Krista he cards her
name into a tree which is a Fern Gully
no no can't you feel it's pain its
nervous system screaming in agony we
need 10 cc's of kind of so much fat so
Krista introduces Zack to the rest of
the Keebler elves as they all analyze
her a friend somehow I thought they'd be
[Music]
I used some pills for that not that I
need any things don't go well when one
of the fairies is threatened because he
used to be the most feminine Male which
results in what else a cock contest why
don't you come with me and the boys will
give you a taste of real ferngully
wildlife unless of course you're not up
to it I'm a anything you can dish out
but
it's my stereo okay I found it so I'll
explain it all right
[Music]
wow that way too inexpensive copyright
your way out of this bug I'll teach him
to move in on my girlfriend sister
[Music]
isn't that right jasmine I mean Krista
maybe we should consult the genie
I mean Betty after all that is why I'm
Sultan I mean King I which animated
movie am I in again come on Zack see
around zag allow me to mispronounce your
name to express my disrespect for you
but krysta steals him away and takes
into what looks like under Three Mile
Island where they have a rather strange
romantic moment
[Music]
Speirs
heeey
now you're pregnant
even though Zack and krysta were gone
for just a few minutes
kristan arises to discover the fastest
tearing down of trees in world history
oh if only we weren't so busy having
fairy sex so the fairies gather together
and decide the only thing to do is this
[Music]
what are they doing
[Applause]
[Music]
are they changing from mint flavor to
raspberry fresh I will go
it's the plot well whatever they did it
all seems to center around Krista is
she's apparently the magical leader of
the tribe now this constant waiting of
my arms isn't working all right
gummy we're going to war oh yeah cuz
every kid will understand the John Wayne
reference Chi if I didn't know any
better I swear they were saying that
pollution and toxins were a bad thing so
that breaks into the Machine and figures
out that the only way to turn off this
Leviathan is to turn off the Leviathan
well that was disappointingly simple it
doesn't even make sense if he feeds off
a pollution what was he feeding on
before the humans came along the asses
of cows but don't worry
through the magic of just magic I guess
hexxus regenerates himself and comes
back to life that makes sense
the num from the brain down but she gets
out her magic bean that turns the Dark
Lord into a chia pet for some reason and
thus all order is restored to Franco II
Zac is transformed back to his normal
size where he'll go home forgetting
about how to save the environment just
like everyone else who watched this
movie except this movie is awful it made
no sense it made no money and it made us
want to chop down as many you could look
this trees as possible I think my
biggest problem with this movie is that
while they're trying to tell us to save
the rainforests and not cut down trees
how many trees do you think they chopped
down to make the paper for this goddamn
animated movie or not to mention the
greatest factual wrong with the movie
which is to infer that the major cause
of deforestation is the goddamn logging
industry it's not it's it's cows
clearing rainforests we need rain
forests and you know they clear them out
for your goddamn hamburgers so even to
environmental nut balls this movie makes
no sense
say that again you mean
[Music]
we remembered so you don't have to